henri sterdyniak bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin alors
bruno le maire se veut rassurant sur la
croissance en 2022 partagez vous son
optimisme
disons à moitié à côté on a bien jure
2002 va t elle que l'économie française
n'était pas très fortement impacté par
le cos vide l'économie française repart
immédiatement dès que les mesures de
confinement sont enlevés donc de ce
point de vue on peut être optimisé de
l'autre côté le rebond au prévue pour
2022 sera regardée de toute évidence
donc on n'atteindra pas le 4% de
croissance
que comptait le gouvernement ne cessera
mais on peut espérer quand même si le co
vide si le nouvelle vague trop dure à
peu près un trimestre que ça reparte et
donc il ya simplement un retard à
l'allumage c'est peu dire alors l'état
qui dispose encore du budget de 2021
près de 2 milliards d'euros de marge de
manoeuvre pour revenir aux entreprises
les plus impactés par cette crise
sanitaire quels sont justement les
secteurs elle les plus touchés par les
nouvelles restrictions
d'abord cette histoire de 1 milliard de
marge de manoeuvre est totalement
fictive vieux vu en donne une valve 2021
que la marge de les marges de manoeuvre
de l'état est très grands d'un fils y
pratiquer mans puisque on peut toujours
sans gaieté sur les marchés financiers
et que la bce soutient
le déficit public n'y a pas de limite à
2 légal par contre bien sûr le
gouvernement d'un côté
continue sa politique de soutien aux
entreprises valle secteur touché c'est
en priorité le tourisme la culture les
loisirs les puis 1 degré moindre sens
good
le transport et le commerce de détail
donc de toute évidence il y aura ne pas
que le gouvernement continue grosso modo
sa politique de quoi qu'il en coûte et
par ailleurs il faut noter que le
gouvernement allait j'ai mes mails et
les mesures de
2,2 isolement des gaules resteront
ouvertes et donc ça limite l'impact
sur l'activité
limite le nombre de personnes qui sont
absentes de leur entreprise attend une
estimation des pertes financières
depuis le début de cette pandémie
concernant certaines entreprises
une estimation qui on peut dire est
légal et relativement satisfaisante
c'est à dire que depuis la pandémie le
taux de marge des entreprises augmenter
au lieu de diminuer c'est à dire que les
aides ont été généralement pratiquement
équivalent à la perte subie par les
entreprises aussi bien le chômage
partiel que les différentes aides faut
compenser les coûts fixes les aides
sectorielles tout ça fait que
globalement les entreprises n'ont pas
vraiment souffert leur endettement à
paris comme massivement augmenté les
entreprises ont pu maintenir leurs
investissements
donc on peut dire le gouvernement à
tirer la leçon des erreurs de politique
économique commune et à la suite de la
crise financière l'a ouvert les vannes
on se retrouve avec un déficit et une
dette publique augmenter et le tout
maintenant c'est de pas les réduire et
rapidement mais on a je pense a toujours
des marges de manoeuvre dans la question
c'est que certaines entreprises ont
commencé à rembourser le prêt garanti
par l'état des premiers confinement est
ce que ces nouvelles aides vont vous
pallier au manque des des entreprises en
question
politiquement le gouvernement feint le
gouvernement a dit clairement que les
autres il y aurait des difficultés à
rembourser ces aides qui auraient des
difficultés à rembourser leurs dettes
sociales et fiscales seront aidés que l
épaule qui pourrait y avoir des records
de de remboursement donc lorsqu'il faut
pas être inquiet à ce sujet évidemment
il y aura des entreprises qui feront qui
seront en difficulté mais s'adapte aux
problèmes qui viennent d'avant le vide à
la plupart des entreprises et notamment
dans les secteurs
secteurs les plus touchés seront
massivement risée par le gouvernement la
politique du quoi qu'il en coûte
elle est sur le fond elle est maintenue
merci beaucoup henri sterdyniak d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste et membre des
économistes atterrés